good morning Hank it's Tuesday October
27 2015 a significant day in YouTube
history because tomorrow YouTube read
launches which may or may not change
online video forever also you will
notice that I trimmed my beard because
nerdfighters had started to refer to it
as the under puff write but youtube read
so until now youtube has always been
like network television and radio before
it an advertising supported medium now
there are obvious advantages to this
creators get paid unlike most social
media sites and also it's free for
viewers but there are also disadvantages
ad supported media tends to seek the
broadest possible audience because what
advertisers really want is the most
possible eyeballs to see their message
and without supported media we generally
end up with stuff that lots of people
will watch over stuff that like some
people who really really love you know
like broad spectrum shows like Law &
Order can succeed but niche shows like
Firefly or Arrested Development can't
also I know you probably don't think
you're affected by advertising but you
are to quote Emily Nussbaum is brilliant
recent essay on what advertising is done
to television our comfort with being
sold to may look like savvy but it feels
like innocence I mean hate corporations
know a lot more about what influences my
consumptive habits than I do that
phenomenon has been studied extensively
sources in the do with you where you can
also find a link to nuts bombs si so ok
having acknowledged my advertising
ambivalence let's explore my YouTube red
ambivalence here's the idea for $10 a
month you can add for YouTube offline
watching and all the music you want so
it's like Spotify plus add for YouTube
also there will be some new original
shows from people like PewDiePie and
other youtubers that are only available
to YouTube red subscribers so Inc the
question I've heard the most from people
is is this good for creators which
speaks a lot to how awesome the YouTube
viewership is the answer that question
is yeah some portion of that $10 per
month will go to the youtubers you watch
I don't really know how much yet and per
viewer YouTube bread will generate more
money for creators than advertising that
said it's like a thousand times more
valuable to support a creator through
patreon or through buying merch than
through either YouTube red or
advertising actually it's not like a
thousand it is a thousand times better
maybe even two thousand the best way to
financially support creators you care
about remains directly so I don't think
that's the reason to get YouTube red but
I do think there are good reasons I mean
I'm gonna get it but anyway in case what
concerns me the most will YouTube red
create two classes of YouTube viewers
those who can pay and those who can't
one of the things that makes YouTube
really special is that edits
it's a flat platform for both creators
and audiences right like I have the same
capacity to reach an audience sitting
here in my basement as a major media
company does and on the audience side if
you have access to a device and the
internet all of YouTube is available to
you now that started to change a little
on the creator side of things as
production values have risen but I
really don't want it to change on the
audience side like YouTube is going to
remain essentially the same for everyone
who doesn't become a read subscriber the
only difference is that you won't have
access to these new high budget original
shows like PewDiePie is making a horror
show with the producers of The Walking
Dead and that sounds awesome and it
would also be completely impossible in
an advertising supported medium but
nerdfighters I wonder if you would be
excited or scared if your favorite
creators did such a show I'm asking for
a friend by the way like it allows
creators to have the kinds of budgets
you can't have for advertising supported
projects but on the other hand it limits
the number of people who can actually
see the thing to read subscribers in
short a I don't know how to feel about
all this stuff
we've always been uncomfortable with
advertising and it's nice to see YouTube
moving away from sole reliance upon it I
think YouTube red will be a good option
for a lot of people without harming the
experience of the majority who stick
without supported YouTube and in general
I think that subscriptions make viewers
more powerful and brand slightly less so
and that's good news but I'm not sure I
want YouTube to look like cable TV when
it grows up
I want YouTube to be driven by the stuff
that makes it interesting by passionate
fan communities who do awesome stuff
together by the direct relationship
between creator and audience I mean at
its best YouTube isn't something you
watch it's something you're part of so
the question becomes is YouTube bred a
step toward that promised land or away
from it I don't know that's not a
rhetorical question I look forward to
continuing the conversation and comments
nerdfighters Hank I'll see you tomorrow
nope Friday gosh I was so in Brotherhood
2.0 mode